and joining us now the secretary of
homeland security
alejandro mayorkas mr secretary welcome
to fox news sunday
good morning and thank you for having me
chris
i want to start with something that
white house press secretary john
jensacke said this week take a look sir
we are taking steps to ensure that when
kids come to the border
we look and see if they have a phone
number in their pocket so we can call
the family member and get them to those
family members as quickly as possible
i understand compassion for these
children
but why is it the responsibility of the
u.s
to resettle minors coming across the
border illegally
chris that is the law under the united
states we have an
asylum program that recognizes
young children young vulnerable
children's right
to claim asylum to claim fear from
persecution by reason of their
membership in a particular
group that is what the law provides and
we administer and enforce those laws
you and the administration talk about
being
humane uh but let's go back to what the
trump policy was
which in the case of non-mexican miners
was not as has been
suggested simply to turn these kids
around and push them back into the
desert
in fact we would coordinate with other
countries we would
charter planes we would send them back
by airplane
to resettle with their families why
is it more humane to take these kids to
put them
in border patrol facilities that were
not meant
for children often times for many more
days than the legal limit
uh chris that is that is not what the
prior administration did you
you'll forgive me uh the prior
administration
did expel children did fly children to
countries
uh where from which they were fleeing
countries that did not have the capacity
to administer asylum claims
countries that suffer tremendous
violence
poverty corruption and other
infirmities so to suggest
that the prior administration handled
the needs of
children in a humane way is just false
well you you seem to have agreed with me
sir that they would put them on planes
they wouldn't just send them back over
the desert
they'd put them on a plane and fly them
back to guatemala or
el salvador are you suggesting that
every miner
the thousands and thousands of miners
coming across this country has a
legitimate
asylum claim and that a lot of them
aren't just coming
across the border because they want to
have a better life here which is
understandable but
isn't necessarily our responsibility
we administer our laws and let me say a
few things if i may
number one the prior administration
dismantled the orderly and safe way that
these children could make their claims
it tore down the central american miners
program
that allow these children to make their
claims under united states law
without having to take the perilous
journey we are rebuilding that process
we are encouraging families
not to send their children along the
dangerous journey because so many do not
make it safely
we are encouraging them not to do so yet
if they arrive at the border we have a
responsibility to allow them to make
their
claims under united states law and to
address
these are vulnerable children to address
their needs
and we can do so in a safe and orderly
manner it takes time
because the entire system was dismantled
we are working on it
and we will succeed because that is what
we do
i'm going to get back to that in a
moment mr secretary but the day
after president biden took office
he made this promise to the american
people take a look
the vice president harris and i and our
entire administration
will always be honest and transparent
with you about both the good news and
the bad
so why has the biden administration
refused to allow reporters to see for
themselves and to record
what the conditions are under which
these miners are being housed why in
fact did you when you went to the border
on friday
and led a congressional delegation why
did you
refuse to allow reporters to see the
conditions
under which these minors are being held
uh two things uh chris if i may number
one
let's not forget that we're in the midst
uh of a pandemic
and we are focused uh on our operations
executing our operations in a crowded
border patrol
facility where hundreds of vulnerable
migrant children
are located number one and number two
we're working on providing footage
so that the american public can see the
border patrol stations
and i would encourage you and other
reporters
to see the facilities under the control
of the health and human services
department
where those children are sheltered and
where they belong
and where we are moving them as quickly
as possible
secretary mallorcas respectfully sir i
i think that there is a safe condition
under which a pool reporter and a pool
camera crew
could go into some of these facilities
this has been going on for two months
now
and record the conditions under which
these miners are being held
it seems to me to say it's impossible to
do because a covid
sounds like an excuse chris
we're working on providing access um so
that individuals uh will be able to see
what
the conditions in a border patrol
station uh are like but first things
first we are in the midst of a pandemic
and we're focused
on operations and executing on our plans
that's our highest priority
but we are providing for that access and
certainly
reporters can see the department of
health and human services facilities
in which children are sheltered for a
longer period of time
texas governor greg albert raised two
concerns
uh this week about conditions in the
camp
for minors in midland texas take a look
sir
so there is no viable usable running
water
at the location in midland and then on
top of that
more than 10 percent of the migrants at
the midland location
have now tested positive for cova 19.
mr secretary why not let reporters go to
see what the conditions are at the camp
in midland
and is it true that more than 10 percent
of the miners in midland
have tested positive and in fact that
more than 200 migrants
in brownsville tested positive for covet
and then were released
chris the miners who are arriving
and who are placed in the department of
health and human services facilities
are tested they are all tested
isolated and quarantined our covet 19
protocols that are administered by the
department of health and human services
are operated very efficiently we also i
should say
work very closely with local officials
in texas
with local organizations to also
test isolate and quarantine
children and we offer
reimbursement 100 percent from fema and
i do hope that governor
abbott reconsiders his position
of not allowing those local
organizations and local
officials to be reimbursed 100 percent
by the federal government that's all in
the service i want to of the public
health imperative
excuse me sir i want to put up uh what
president biden has done on immigration
policy in just his first
two months in office he halted part of
title 42
to allow unaccompanied minors to stay in
the u.s during the pandemic he ended the
provision
that asylum seekers must remain in
mexico while their cases are being heard
and he suspended the safe third country
agreements to share
asylum seekers with other countries you
put out this statement on tuesday
we are on pace to encounter more
individuals on the southwest border
than we have in the last 20 years mr
secretary
do you not see a connection between the
surge in the
at the border and the policy changes
that
joe biden has made in his first two
months
chris i do not what i am seeing is the
result and what we are seeing
is the result of president trump's
dismantlement
of the safe and orderly immigration
processes that
were built over many many years
by presidents of both parties that's
what we are seeing and that's why it's
taking time
for us to execute our plans to
administer the humanitarian claims of
vulnerable children
that's what this is about this is about
vulnerable children
and let me say one thing as well if i
may chris safe
third country agreements is misnamed
there's nothing safe about it to return
people to the very countries from which
they are fleeing
persecution that's just false and we
have replaced the remaining mexico
policy
with a safe and orderly uh triage system
working with our partners in mexico and
humanitarian organizations
in the international space and we are
not expelling
vulnerable children at the same time we
are encouraging them
not to take the dangerous journey
because we are rebuilding orderly
processes for them
as well as our country has always had
uh until the prior administration
uh one final question sir you you say
that you're encouraging minors not to
come across the message clearly isn't
getting through
it's true that the number of people
coming across the border
began to increase in the final months of
the trump administration but there
has been a big sharp spike since joe
biden has come on and i want to put up
some of the numbers here 74
000 border apprehensions in trump's
final month
full month of december 100 000
in joe biden's first full month in
february
just under 5 000 unaccompanied minors
came across the border
apprehended in trump's final month of
december
9 400 in december in february
the numbers rose dramatically
after president biden took office after
he changed the policies and in addition
for all your talk about minors
the fact is sir according to cbp border
patrol
numbers 58.87 percent of the family
units that came across in february
have been allowed to stay in this
country you are not returning them the
vast majority of them
back south of the border
chris of a few points so you mentioned
that the numbers began to spike up
admittedly in the last couple months of
the trump administration
actually the numbers began to spike in
april of 2020.
the numbers were extremely high
throughout 2019 this administration does
not like they have been in february
arms of their parents
chris we do expel families
we are working with mexico to increase
mexico's capacity
to receive the expelled families the
border is secure
the border is closed we've been
unequivocal
in that and we are operationalizing our
processes
executing our plans we are a nation of
laws and we treat vulnerable children
humanely
we can do it and we are doing it
secretary mayorkas thank you thanks for
your time this weekend thank you for
answering all our questions and please
come back sir
i look forward to it and thank you chris